احدث حاله طلب اللجوء هذه المره من بطله
التزلج الايرانيه عاطف احمد
المانيا عاطف احمد
المتزلجه الاولى في ايران حامله العلم
الايراني في الاولمبياد الشتويه
والوحيده التي شاركت في اولمبياد بكين
وعده ميداليات ذهبيه
لا تنوي المشاركه في بطوله العالم بفرنسا
مع اعضاء اخرين من فريق التزلج الوطني
الايراني وطلبت اللجوء الى المانيا هذا
القرار الشخصي ويبدو انه تم التخطيط له
لفتره طويله وامل ان يكون هذا الخبر غير
صحيح
لاعبه الشطرنج الاولى في ايران فراسات
لاعب المنتخب الايراني
نجم كره قدم الايراني
اسماء رياضيه ايرانيه تجاوزت الستينما
جميعها تقدمت بطلبات اللجوء الى عدد من
الدول الاجنبيه تزايدت بشكل متسارع في
الاشهر الاخيره بعد موجه الاحتجاجات التي
تشهدها ايران منذ سبتمبر الماضي على اثر
مقتل الفتاه ماسا امين